what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so uh I am moving I am moving to
Colorado and usually whenever I go on
like trips around moving or something
like that I just kind of throw out some
pretty easy to digest stories let they
do complicated or nothing too wild we
finished Jason Aaron's run on me
Incredible Hulk which i think is a
pretty good stopping point after that I
think it doesn't really get very
interesting and we can just kind of dead
end into the events of all-new
all-different marvel but for this video
I wanted to cover the 198 because this
deals with the god Newton it deals with
mr. M Absalom Mercator this guy is nuts
like it's crazy the kind of things that
he can do now he had appeared in Marvel
Comics prior to the events of house of M
and he took up residence in a place
called mutant town now those guys who
don't know mutant town was one of these
places in the realm of Marvel Comics
there was basically home to mutants for
a lot of different people so the idea
was that it was really like a mutant
only area but it was really kind of like
for castoffs or people who really can
just found their way who weren't part of
the excellent they weren't part of a
villain team just kind of like a
no-man's land for a lot of the mutant
population some chose to live there some
chose to live regular lives and live
other places but the fact remains that
Absalon it kind of found a place for
himself there by just being a handyman
that's really all he did he just kind of
hung out and that was really about it
but he's a guy that has the ability to
work reality and so it was really kind
of crazy in terms of stuff he can do
truth be told what we see here in this
story I think is about as extreme as his
powers ever got in terms of us seeing
what it is he can do but it's pretty
impressive too some of the things that
he can pull off but the one 98 this
story takes place almost immediately
after the events of house of M which is
to say after The Scarlet Witch works
reality and in fact it actually picks up
with magma now magma has a character
who's been around for a long time she
was made by Bob McLeod I think it was in
Chris Claremont but she goes back quite
a way she was part of the New Mutants
she was part of the Hellions she had a
relationship with empath for a while
which is actually something this invoked
in the story but at the time that this
aspect is being done you know this era
in her life she is a teacher for the
Xavier Institute and it actually gone on
vacation with her boyfriend Antonia now
as far as I'm aware there's not a lot of
information given about Antonia
where magma has the ability to you know
literally manipulate magma and so on and
so forth Antonia looks like a guy who
can manipulate fire and the two actually
go together pretty well so we actually
convinces her to leap like to take an
extra extra week on our vacation and you
just go so like la cumbre thing is what
it is
volcano basically and just kind of poke
around and have fun and explore their
powers and so on clockwork the problem
with this is that remember when the
Scarlet Witch warped reality and she
basically created house of N and then
said no more mutants and set everything
back what it did is it created this wave
that's spread throughout the world and
just started stripping people of their
powers so it's like an ocean of power
there was just riding around the planet
and people were just losing their
abilities when it passed over them in
this instance the loss of Antonio's
powers coincide with the fact that
they're inside a volcano so he's
literally melted alive just by the sheer
heat and the magma itself magma would
have been able to stop this right like
she would have been able to prevent it
but it happened so quickly and so
suddenly that there was no saving this
guy so in a fit of rage she loses her
mind and lashes out now from here we
pick up with a couple of ancillary
characters you know for example a group
called purity now purity is not to be
confused with William strikers purifiers
there are a whole different organization
and they'll be focused on you know in
the events of Messiah Complex assuming
that we get around to it but the purity
group is really more of just like street
thugs masquerading as hey we're making
the streets pure of mutants so on and so
forth the following the events of house
of M with word getting around to a lot
of people in the world that you know 2.8
some odd million mutants have basically
lost their powers that what this does is
it sets in motion the idea of a lot of
these anti-mutant groups rising to
prominence more so than they were before
instead of slinking around in the
shadows taking potshots here and there
they effectively came out of hiding
because now they have the courage where
they're being soaked you mutants left
and so because of this it immediately
draws the attention of a guy by the name
of toad of course a young woman is
attacked you know because of the fact
that these purity guys are kind of crazy
but toad of course helps her out but
this girl was basically scalped in the
process now in terms of Absalom mercator
himself we actually end up picking up in
Bellevue Hospital with the psychiatric
wing and the arrival of Absalom locator
now of course what he does is he
actually meets a girl by the name of
Hanna Levi now Hanna Levi was a girl who
basically had a tongue like a prehensile
tongue like toad but she had no real
like crazy powers right like she's like
a telepath or a telekinetic or anything
like that but she's drawn the attention
of mr. M because they were friends of
mutant towns so again mr. M's kind of
going after those people that he was
friends with individuals who may have
lost their powers or something along
those lines but Hanna Levi is basically
a crazy chick you know she was more or
less insane an Absalom mercator actually
cures her of her insanity by basically
reworking the synapses
her ring but of course absalon's also
aware of the fact that mutants
everywhere have bendy power and so
hannah basically you know but sieges him
to actually travel over to the Xavier
Institute and see if it's possible to
fix the various mutant population to see
if he can either restore their powers or
the very least try to provide some
measure of order now the crazy thing
about his character is he actually
arrives at the Xavier Institute and when
he does he phases through a solid wall
and immediately takes out the sentinels
now these are not the signals that
you're used to these signals belong to
the office of national emergency now the
office of national emergency was
basically organized some structured for
two purposes the first was to deal with
the possibility of mutant threats and
the second was to protect the mutant
population in the event that something
like this happened and so what happened
is you know following the events of
house of M what we had talked about in
decimation was the idea that the office
of national emergency was mobilized the
sentinels as they exist here are
actually man meaning they're not
autonomous they're controlled by
individual people and they basically
stand outside in a lab the Xavier
Institute to keep people in and to keep
people from getting out and so because
of this with epsilon just kind of
showing up and just walking through
walls effectively some people view him
as something akin to a to a mutant
Messiah
while others view him as a dangerous of
course the x-men of the ones that view
him as being the most dangerous in this
example Emma Frost and Cyclops but of
course they're also in somewhat of a
weird situation too because prior to
this there was a lot of Xavier going on
this since the prior to Xavier taking
off hanging out with magneto while The
Scarlet Witch was being dealt with
before she warped reality Xavier would
basically answer these questions teach
people the things they needed to know so
right now Cyclops and Emma Frost are
flying by the seat of their pants
because the first instance in which they
basically become headmaster and
headmistress of the school officially
meaning that they are basically running
everything on their own
absent Charles Xavier in his entirety
which means no one knows where he is
things go absolutely arrived everybody's
looking at the Xavier Institute as a
safe refuge things are about as crazy as
they can get and then suddenly they had
this guy epsilon just shows up and he's
doing things like automatically evolving
organisms manipulating reality on a
scale that people can't really begin to
comprehend not only that this girl
Lorelei who had basically you know been
scalped by these purity guys he just
immediately regrows her hair this is the
kind of power that we're talking about
here and so leading to the war room a
conversation between the x-men you know
the core members of the group addressing
everything that's going on the first
thing that comes up you know for
discussion its mr. M himself now of
course going through their analysis
looking at his powers looking what he's
capable of the first thing they say is
this guy is an omega-level mutant now in
truth mr. M is beyond Omega level
there's only a handful of mutants who
are like that but he is a beyond
omega-level mutant meaning that there is
no limit to the abilities that he has
and he's a universal threat which means
that he could presumably be you know
kind of evolved into this Universal
being a cosmic entity or something along
those lines now that's usually the case
when it comes to people who can work
reality on such a scale in the same way
that he can so forth where the x-men
can't really wage war against a guy like
this because of the fact that he seems
to be coming in peace they just kind of
let things go and say look you know
we'll keep an eye on him we'll just kind
of keep things in check and we'll
eventually see what's going on now with
regards to the 198 and this sort of
turmoil that begins to erupt this all
really starts from the idea that some of
them want to leave and this is when we
start running into the issue of no one
gets in no one gets out so for those
people who are in here some of them look
at it as a safety place you know look at
it saying look these various extremist
groups cannot get to us for others they
look at it and say this is a prison
we're not allowed to leave now of course
what this does is this brings in Valerie
Cooper now Valerie Cooper has a
long-standing history in Marvel Comics
she was basically you know the the
government liaison for x-factor but by
being associated with the x-factor team
which in turn was associated with the
x-men it made her friends to a wide
array of the mutant population when it
came to superheroes and it made her an
enemy to a lot of villains Valerie
Cooper's about the closest thing the
x-men have to a friend when it comes to
the government sector of the United
States so because of this Valerie
Cooper's the one that basically
organized all this stuff she's head of
the Office of national emergency she's
the one that's basically safeguarding
the mutants but ultimately this
rebellion or this revolution of sorts is
leading to some turmoil just because of
the fact that there are those who want
to leave but they're not really allowed
to leave now of course Absalom Mercator
steps up yet again in the middle of this
conflict and basically says look you
guys don't need to be fighting he
literally brings everything to a halt
like he just stops the signals and
simply just again gives us another
display of the extreme power that he
possesses here this is just the tip of
the iceberg the stuff he's going to do
later on it's going to be absolutely
nuts but we also pick up with a guy by
the name of John Dee
now John Dee is kind of a weird
situation here and the reason why I say
that is because the fact that John Dee
or Johnny Dee or whatever you want to
call is basically a new introduction to
marvel
comics but he's kind of strange he has
this weird appendage in his chest but
what it basically does is it creates
voodoo dolls of people so all he has to
do was introduce a strand of DNA and
it'll pop out this little voodoo doll
that he can basically control to make it
do almost anything he wants to in this
first instance because of the fact that
he had spoken with magma because he had
pulled a piece of her hair it ultimately
gives him the ability to make a sort of
voodoo doll of her that he can use for
you know whatever purpose and her
physical body will do whatever it is
that he does with that doll now of
course from here we pick up with his
first major revolution among the 198 and
the reason why is because of the fact
that these mutants who are residing
within the Xavier Institute are
basically told look because of the fact
that some of you guys wanted to leave we
can allow you to do that but the problem
is you cannot leave unsupervised and
this is the danger of this whole thing
and truth valerie cooper has the best
interest of a mutant population at heart
she's literally doing what she believes
to be the right thing and what she says
is we are going to allow you guys to
leave under two conditions the first is
that you guys carry an emergency cell
phone you know so that you guys can
basically contact the office of national
emergency if anything pops off people
try to attack you or ever the case may
be but we're also going to tag you guys
so that we can keep track of your
location now the first part isn't a huge
thing walk around with a cell phone
whatever most folks would probably just
make long-distance calls and probably
abuse it but the problem with being
tagged is it now they feel like animals
and rightfully so because that's the
whole crazy thing about this one thing
you guys got to keep in mind is that
when it comes to a lot of these mutants
who are residing within the Xavier
Institute they all come from different
walks of life some of whom who have
extremely exotic appearances took up
residence in mutant town where they
didn't have to worry about the
oppression of people others were
Morlocks they resided underground not
all of them had the benefit of walking
around like Emma Frost with no one
having any idea that they have to levity
or some power they're simply
undetectable by physical appearance and
so for a lot of these folks all they've
known is struggle and strife all they've
known is people giving them a hard time
because of their physical appearance or
because of the way their powers manifest
or because they can't control their
abilities or any number of things and
then to be told hey look this is a safe
haven that you cannot leave unless you
allow yourself to be imprinted with the
tag this inevitably leads to conflict it
inevitably leads to battle between all
these different individuals now of
course what also ends up happening here
is we end up finding out that again
Johnny D's been going through and making
all these different voodoo dolls of all
these different mutants that
with an the Xavier Institute now it
doesn't have all 198 but it still makes
it pretty dangerous because he gets
single-handedly instigate a rebellion in
and of himself now at this point we
actually pick up with a guy by the name
of memo max I think it is how you
pronounce his name but he's a guy who
basically has the form of an elephant
for the problem with this is he's one of
a handful of individuals who left who
agreed to getting tagged and then
ultimately ended up taking off the
problem with this is that when he's
basically insulted by a normal person
and begins to lash out what we end up
finding out is that where Valerie Cooper
was told these tags only serve the
purpose of monitoring where these
mutants go we actually end up learning
that these tags also contain an electric
shock that will literally keep them in
check that will keep them from lashing
out and if they do lash out it'll
basically shock them and subdue that now
the reason why this is so significant is
because of the fact that the fear of
these mutants comes true they're
basically being treated like animals if
they act out they get an electric shock
and should they learn what to do and
what not to do they're very much being
treated like dogs the other half of this
is that one of these guys basically goes
about sort of you know doing his own
thing but he's a drug addict now we're a
voodoo doll had been created by Johnny D
Johnny D begins to experiment begins to
toy around
and in the process strangles the voodoo
doll which in turn kills this mute
another problem with jazz basically
dying here is that people don't know
exactly why and mutants these various
meetings you feel threatened begin to
make false corollaries what they
basically say is well mammal max over
there said that he was shocked by his
tag and jazz over here died so that
means that the tags are killing people
that's the conclusion that they come to
you now Valerie Cooper is basically told
look here's the whole reason why this
was being done of course getting the
information from her superior general
laser at the Pentagon who's really the
guy kind of spearheading this whole
thing and what he does is he actually
makes a legitimate case he says look the
reason why we tagged these guys is
because when you have that many people
from that many walks of life who are all
confined in a singular space it's only a
matter of time before something pops off
whether we're the ones that caused it
whether they caused it on their own they
were inevitably going to lose their
minds
you know to paraphrase star wars they're
animals and we're treating them like
animals because in a lot of ways they're
acting out just like children but the
other half of this is that they're
terrified all they know is that some of
them died and they don't know why or at
least one of them died and they don't
know why and so when their life is on
the line and they feel like prisoners
it's a return to the life that they
tried to escape from when they join the
Xavier
institute in the first place and so
ultimately what ends up happening is in
the middle of all this fray
Absalom Mercator shows up and starts
taking people's tags out of their necks
you know because it's tagged you're
attached to their skulls they can't pull
them off on their own but he begins
popping out you know their tags using
his ability to transmit matter and
basically says look by the declaration
of cyclops himself those who don't want
to be here are allowed to leave so if
anybody wants to leave with me we're
walking out of here and there's nothing
they're going to be able to do to stop
me which there isn't there's nothing
they can do to stop him and this is when
we get another example of his
reality-warping power he walks up to the
eastern wall and transmits matter so he
basically breaks the wall apart and
creates a doorway for himself that's the
kind of power we're dealing with here
that's why it's so crazy and that's why
it's so extreme because what do you do
with a guy who can literally do anything
when he's reading all these people what
he's doing things like walking on water
that's why things become so dangerous
because now
Absalon mercator it's not this mutant
that has the ability to walk reality now
he's a messiah people look at him and
say oh he's going to lead us to the
promised land they look at the extreme
power he possesses and they start
viewing him as a mutant God and so
that's why things get really really
dangerous here because now faith comes
into the equation this inevitably leads
to Cyclops and him across and so on
these guys showing up where Absalom
Mercator has taken these mutants this
little island right outside of the
Xavier Institute and says you guys have
to come back now keep in mind
Cyclops does not want a battle here one
because they have no hope of winning if
they were to actually fight Absalom
Mercator under normal circumstances and
to because of the fact that he's trying
to preserve what's left of the mutant
population they'd be in population when
it comes to people who gained powers
it's not like normal humans with mutants
there's no guarantee that if mutants
procreate that another mutant could be
born we've seen a litany of stories when
a mutant gene suddenly just ends it just
stops and that's really the concern that
mutants have here is because with there
being no guarantee that two mutants
procreating will lead to another mutant
their numbers at 198 are small enough as
it is and it's entirely possible for
that with 98% of mutants losing their
powers there will be no mutants born now
of course that's really the premise of
everything that takes place between this
story and Messiah Complex with the birth
of Hope Summers but that's still a very
legitimate concern for Cyclops and its
crew and so what is it happening here is
where a conflict initially you know
begins to erupt and we end up finding
out that Johnny G is basically
manipulating the bodies
these various mutants to instigate a
conflict we also end up learning that
Johnny D is basically working for the
office of national emergency working for
general laser and putting his powers to
nefarious uses literally instigating a
conflict that will result and this sort
of mass destruction among all these
mutants and stuff what is it happening
here is Epsilon just kind of les loups
he literally just like in cases
everybody and says no one is going to
fight there is not going to be any
conflict here you will not harm my
people now again this is an extreme
demonstration of power because of the
guy that can work reality if he's angry
at you then you're probably done with
all your living and that's exactly
what's going on here I mean he's not
really killing people but it's the
possibility that was a wave of his hand
suddenly everybody except his people are
gone any number of things could happen
that's the kind of power that you're
dealing with we end up having Johnny G
using his powers along you know to
basically create this conflict between
these mutants but with Absalom mercator
having such extreme abilities his
attention immediately focuses on him and
so where a lot of these mutants are
acting against their own characters
where they're doing things they wouldn't
normally do Johnny D basically uses the
power of leech to touch Absalom Mercator
and take his power away now this is a
pretty significant thing because
remember when it comes to the character
of leech he was always identified as a
mutant that had the ability to touch
other people and suppress the mutant
powers but we didn't know how far that
went
really up until this story we didn't
know if there was like an upper echelon
where there's just a level of power they
just cannot deactivate because it's
intrinsic to the environment around them
that's really the way a lot of meeting
powers work with the character of
Absalom Mercator if you can work reality
on a universal scale does that mean that
he's part and parcel to the universe
itself and if so is reached trying to
deactivate his power the exact same
thing is trying to destroy eternity
Absalom being able to manipulate reality
is just a byproduct of his mutant factor
and if leach can shut off his power he
can turn off the power of anybody that
he comes across so I would surmise that
in truth leach is probably the most
powerful mutant in the world by virtue
of the fact did the best defense or the
best offense is a strong defense if you
can shut off the power of anybody that
exists who's going to oppose you I mean
all the way take is leech with a handgun
walking around the world and the mutant
population doesn't exist anymore the
fact remains shutting off the power of
Absalom Mercator also allows Johnny G to
basically manipulate the power of magma
and destroy absalon's physical body so
again it's kind of a MacGuffin kind of a
caveat that leads to epsilon Mercator
being defeated
effectively demoralized the entirety of
the rebel population among this mutant
group but ultimately what this means now
is they just resigned to their fate they
don't know what's going to happen next
and so in this last little moment here
what we end up finding out is that where
funerals more or less being held this
kind of visitation for mr. M that is
coffins actually empty and that he's
kind of evolved into a next you know
stage of evolution in the sense they
just kind of manifest as butterflies
it's kind of weird
they got like butterflies he comes back
as butterflies I don't really know but
it really just kind of ends on the Thai
note basically saying that nothing ever
really dies things just sort of evolved
and it's this kind of positive note that
is going it's kind of a calm before the
storm and it sense that everything
following this gets pretty dark for the
x-men things get pretty brutal
nonetheless this really just kind of
covers the events immediately following
the house of M everything after this
basically leads out to like second
coming Messiah Complex it's world lights
with cyborgs all that kind of get stuff
in and after that it leads in like the
Dark Reign era the heroic age all those
different things like that but enemy
then if you guys are new here to come
this explain make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
pour if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]